i've read something from the mail online
right now this brady really sent me a
link to this
and um it combines all my worst
i don't know bug bears all of the things
that really irritate me grind my gears
get me under my get under my skin first
of all it's the daily mail that's why i
send it to you i know i know it's a
daily mail which is the bastion of
reactionary right
of center
news
and um storytelling in in the uk the uk
would be a hell of a lot better britain
would be a hell of a lot better if we
didn't have a daily mail that's the
first thing
then it's combined with um well as you
can see quantum physics proves that
there is an afterlife and claims like
one expert claims he is evidence to
confirm an existence beyond the grave
and it lies in quantum physics so now
we're getting into the area of quantum
physics woo
and the whole idea that you know
there's a fantastical element to quantum
mechanics we're all one part of one
integrated interconnected whole um the
the the weird and wacky and wonderful
stuff that that happens right down at
the atomic molecular level and weird and
wacky and wonderful stuff does happen
down there somehow magically transmute
so magically you can scale up to the
real world so we've got all these
fascinating effects happening in sort of
everyday length scales it's really
frustrating because this this doesn't
seem to be new stuff i don't quite know
why this has suddenly come to the fore
but it's this guy called robert lanza
now robert lanza is obviously a very
clever guy he's done a lot of really
neat work in stem cell research it seems
i'm not a stem cell researcher so um i
haven't read his work in detail but what
i do know is that he's got no background
in physics and of course the usual
argument is oh that means that's great
because he's coming from left field he
control the establishment that eight
ideas away and he'll come up with these
radical new ideas that's sort of like me
going well you know i've absolutely no
background in surgery but i'll tell you
what i'm gonna go in i'm gonna get in
there at the operating table i'm going
to develop some really new techniques
oh dear i've made a mess it's you know
the the argument that you know left to
field ideas can come from you know very
different places than you might expect
that's true but you know
what's what's the quota fortune favors
the prepared mind you know there has to
be some level of background that you
you've got to think about what the the
history of the field has been you've got
to try and work your way through what
he's basically saying is actually not
that much different from a book called
the tower of physics very famous book
it's been out there now i guess since
the 70s i can't quite remember maybe
even the 60s
and what it does is it connects new age
ideas sort of eastern mysticism with
quantum mechanics and quantum physics
the idea that you know quantum physics
means that there's an interconnectedness
to all things and where there's a
universal spirit etc all these type of
things which are deeply deeply
frustrating because quantum physics
really says no such thing at all and um
what lans has done is he's gone a little
bit further and he's basically taken the
old idea of um the observer affecting a
measurement or the observer affecting an
object to say that actually there is no
um objective reality out there there is
no universe out there it's our
consciousness it's our biochemistry that
creates the universe
i need a bit of deep breath because it
is frustrating ah how can i put an awful
lot of nonsense in this let's be
sympathetic for a minute
what has the world of quantum mechanics
and physicists done wrong
that allows people to start making these
connections that you think are spurious
that's a really great question and i
think i'm as guilty of this as everyone
else because when you're down at the
atomic molecular single particle level
weird things do happen things that we
don't understand but because we don't
understand them doesn't mean we can just
make up any nonsense we can't just say
right we don't understand some aspect of
quantum mechanics then i don't know
that's because invisible pixies which
are undetectable to us are popping in
and out of existence and affecting the
forces between these particles we don't
have a license to just make a bull
problem is all the weird and wacky stuff
that happens at the atomic molecular
level like particles of this
jewel or schizophrenic character where
they have behave like waves you know we
haven't got to the bottom of that we we
really don't understand what's going on
now in particular something called
quantum entanglement where you know
what's um
lanza
describes at at length and he's right in
that it is weird and it is strange in
that you get two particles
you couple them together in some weird
state it's called an entangled state i'm
not going to go into details for the
physicists among you you you know it's
all about spin and all that type of
thing but um you'd have a couple of them
in in some state called an entangled
state that's all we need to go into you
send one particle to one end of the
universe if the universe's ends the
other particle to the other end of the
universe you make a measurement on this
one and here's the the weird bit the bit
that cause causes so many physicists so
many sleepless nights is that you make a
measurement in this one and this one
responds instantaneously not at the
speed of light instantaneously
there's clearly something
you know that we're lacking there we
don't understand that it's a remarkable
effect
but
physicists work extremely hard to try
and see these effects like ultra high
vacuums and very very very low
temperatures those type of effects do
not scale up to the macroscopic world
the reason all this quantum weirdness we
don't see it in the microscopic world
you know i don't diffract um like a wave
when i go through a door um brady is is
a fairly solid object in front of me
it's you know it doesn't seem to have
wave-like characteristics at all and
that's because we interact with
ultimately it's because we interact with
our environment and that doesn't require
consciousness it's just you know just
the very fact that these waves these
quantum waves are getting scattered of
objects that's enough we don't need a
consciousness to be an observer and
that's one of the difficulties
with this is the um
sort of anthropomorphic
uh aspect of this is that you're
assuming that nature um
that that reality has to be observed by
a conscious observer to create this
stuff to come back to your question
brady which is a great question you know
to be fair we're so desperate to put
across look at how weird and wonderful
this stuff is it's it's fascinating and
it is fascinating but the difficulty is
is that sometimes that's misinterpreted
and um
quite how we get beyond that quite how
we maintain look at how exciting this is
and yet get across that well actually
you've got to be very careful before you
extend this to larger scales physicists
are very guilty
for various reasons of borrowing
language from the macroscopic world to
describe
this world don't they you know we talk
about colors and flavors of quarks and
we talk and you you borrow all this
language to help people understand yeah
and then it's misinterpreted yeah i i
agree um quark is actually a pretty good
one because that's a i would argue
that's a you know
otherworldly word it doesn't connect
really to the the the the world around
us color is a problem but one of the
things um
spin is a big problem because spin is is
not spin that's that's the difficulty
it's not spin as we think it because um
if you do the calculation it turns out
that if spin at the quantum level was
actually spin things would be spinning
around at so many times the speed of
light so it's yeah it is a problem
thank you brady and we didn't even
prepare this at all so i've been reading
this this is probably the exclusion
principle which um it's remarkable you
can see the origin and validation of a
scientific principle and um this
principle i'm not going to go into it
but it's to do with spin and actually
without this principle we wouldn't have
a periodic table but it's absolutely
remarkable because paulie didn't
introduce it to spin he called it
something i translated vaguely from the
german something along the lines of a
two-valued electron thing and that
eventually became spin
and
it's not quite spin it's definitely not
spin it's a i think most physicists
would think of it as a it's a property
of an electron and we label it as plus
or minus a half but actually what it
physically represents is something very
very difficult indeed lanza
it basically exploits that i would say
there's another line in this daily mail
article lanza uses the example of the
way we perceive the world around us a
person sees a blue sky sky and is told
that the color they are seeing is blue
but the cells in a person's brain could
be changed to make the sky look green or
red
yeah okay that's that's that's fine i'm
not an expert in the biochemistry but
yeah i can see how that might be the
case but that's like arguing that there
isn't an objective color there but we
can measure an objective color because
we know the wavelength or we can measure
the wavelength of the light that might
our brains might perceive that as red or
green or blue whatever but we know what
that wavelength is or what the frequency
of that light is so there's an objective
color there and it's this
mixing of you know
quantum ideas with the idea of what is
subjective and what is objective i guess
that makes this
for physicists so painful to read but
for others who don't you know don't have
the background in physics they read this
and go well he's using lots of big words
here physicists use those same type of
big words then therefore i i don't want
to sound too patronizing but you know
there could be an argument well you know
the language there seems to be the
language of a physicist so maybe he's um
maybe he's onto something here and when
you couple that with you know he's
coming from left failure there's no
training in physics it it's it's really
oh it's it's really a neat story it's a
compelling story in terms of the lone
are really battling against the system
to show that he's got a wonderful new um
out you know out of left field theory
why does it matter
because no physicist is going to accept
this and he hasn't said anything that's
going to make the average reader go and
jump off a cliff or do something stupid
why does it matter that some people
think that maybe a misguided article is
accurate because it changes the
perception of physics it changes the
perception of the world around us and my
job as a physicist and everyone's job as
a physicist is to understand the world
around us and moreover we're funded
we're funded by the public the reason we
do these videos the reason we produce
papers is to disseminate our work to say
look this is the way the world is and
that's why it
hacks off
so many physicists is because it's false
it's just fundamentally wrong it's like
i don't know it's you're a journalist
brady it's like somebody coming up you
you work really really hard to you know
get the detail of a story and
tell that as accurately as possible and
then some likely in the daily mail
journalists comes along and um gives a
completely distorted version of the
facts it would it would hack you off and
for physicists it's
it's not only dangerous from that
perspective in terms of the overall
public perception it's also dangerous in
terms of you know where
how politicians view
what's what's happening because you know
politicians who are in many cases don't
have a strong scientific background may
well read this and think oh wow and if
they've got any sort of um
influence i guess on the funding system
and the funding ecosystem if you want to
call it that then you know this could
direct funding away from something which
is a hell of a lot more valuable into
this this type of nonsense
in this particular system you can't it
doesn't work for this system it doesn't
work for so many systems because what
you have to do is to have a limit to
have an upper limit on the total amount
of energy you can have